sabemos que eeuu tiene un déficit de
comercio más grande comparado con china
y en el 2009 se importaron se importaron
260 mil millones más de los que se
exportaron hacia china y sabemos por los
últimos vídeos que la forma en la que
china está manteniendo y evitando que su
moneda se aprecie en esta falta de
equilibrio comercial es imprimir dinero
y usar esos iones para cambiarlos por
dólares y comprar bienes aquí vemos en
el 2006 2007 2008 aumentos tremendos en
los bienes de eeuu comprados por china y
lo que es un poco más interesante fue
que en el 2009 no se tuvo un aumento tan
grande digo sí se tuvo un aumento pero
no tan grande como para compensar el
balance en el comercio entonces como es
que china puede hacer que su moneda
quede fija bueno vamos a ver la
información y esto no es sólo para el
gobierno de china
son bienes de eeuu que fueron comprados
por nacionales chinos pero aquí podemos
ver los principales extranjeros dueños
de títulos del tesoro y esto viene de
esta página web 3.2 y nos dice que tanto
diferentes bancos centrales básicamente
qué cantidad de títulos del tesoro
fueron comprados por estos bancos
federales podemos ver que china es el
mayor dueño si vemos en noviembre del
2009 tiene 929 mil millones de dólares
929 mil millones de dólares que tiene el
gobierno de china en el año 2009 y esto
es en títulos del tesoro de eeuu pero lo
interesante aquí es que si vamos de
noviembre del 2009 a noviembre del 2010
sus títulos
de hecho bajaron bajo la cantidad de
títulos que tenían
los digo siguen teniendo casi 900 mil
millones pero si bajaron y dado el hecho
de que tenemos este déficit comercial y
el hecho de que ellos quieren mantener
fija su moneda y quieren imprimir dinero
para comprar bienes de otras personas de
otros países cómo es que ocurrió esto
cómo es que bajó el número de títulos
del tesoro que tenían y también cómo es
posible que redujeron la cantidad de los
bienes propiedades de extranjeros en
eeuu bueno lo que nos responde el tesoro
es que ellos no tienen que comprar
títulos ellos pueden comprar otros
bienes de eeuu y lo que vemos aquí es
que pues tampoco compraron mucha
cantidad de bienes de eeuu lo que sucede
aquí es que y bueno no es exactamente lo
que está pasando lo que está pasando es
mucho más complicado como lo hemos visto
en otros vídeos lo que sucede aquí es
que vemos a otros países cuyos títulos
del tesoro de eeuu se han estado
incrementando dramáticamente en el curso
del año 2010
particularmente vemos al reino unido-
sus títulos han aumentado de 155.000
millones
a 511 mil millones y esto es solamente
durante el año 2010 y aquí el reino
unido no tiene un desbalance comercial
con los estados unidos y de hecho
podemos ver nosotros podemos ver que el
valor de su manera realmente no ha
cambiado demasiado durante el año 2010
ha estado siendo más o menos el mismo
aunque bueno esta gráfica luce más
dramática de lo que en verdad es así que
la respuesta aunque bueno puede ser un
poquito más complicada de lo que les voy
a decir es que china ha decidido
diversificarse y no sólo compras títulos
del tesoro de eeuu quizás está
diversificando a la libra esterlina
quizás se diversifican al euro por lo
que ellos podemos decir que van a estar
comenzando a comprar bienes británicos
pero los británicos dicen pues que ellos
no quieren que su moneda se aprecie ya
que si no ellos van a sufrir
consecuencias mercantiles sus bienes se
volverán demasiado caros por lo que el
banco central británico y ya que su
moneda no está muy apreciada con
respecto al dólar
ellos irán a comprar bienes de eeuu y
esto es lo que parece que está
sucediendo y quizá otro pequeño punto es
que el gobierno chino poco a poco está
permitiendo a su moneda a apreciarse un
poquito pero la precisión no es muy
dramática al menos no como lo está
haciendo ver esta gráfica esto es de 6.8
y el dólar al principio del año 2010 y
ha llegado hasta 6 puntos 6 así que esto
es de 6.8 a 6.6 no es demasiada cantidad
de diferencia pero durante los últimos
años los chinos han permitido que poco a
poquito se vaya apreciando su moneda
pero lo que realmente sucede es que se
están diversificando de manera que ya no
sólo compran exclusivamente bienes de
eeuu y cuando compran otras monedas pues
estos otros países comprarán a su vez
bienes de eeuu para mantener el valor de
su moneda fijo